[Music]
I've been having it this strangest
dreams
Rachel dreams are not reliable
analytical material that's so 20th
century
[Music]
but you know that we've had movement on
our waitlist
we got a spot at the womb Center
but I haven't told Albie yet oh why
Rachel
[Music]
he wants a natural child
but hold on you put us on a waitlist to
have a baby in the name no it's not an
egg it's it's an egg
women are reluctant to have children
because it's not made convenient we want
them to pursue their careers and dreams
we can't live in the past I want to have
a child with you that's
I'm sure you're all very excited parents
are raving about it it is the ultra
solution
my nephew was born at the boom Center
but he doesn't dream I wouldn't worry
about it
[Music]
I can't do it with a pot in here what
are you talking about it can't see us
I feel Alvey is able to bond with a
child but I'm not maybe I'm just not
ready to be a mother you know no one's a
mother just like that you become one
we are considering having a home birth
I'm sorry it's not possible I won't
raise this child without nature
congratulations it's so exciting isn't
it
just a change in productivity you do
have a baby at the womb center right why
[Music]
your family Dynamics are about to
undergo true none this changes
how can we make sure our baby's not
bored in utero oh yeah we don't want any
bored babies
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]